ihr seid nur sagt das doch herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video es geht
heute um rosmarin und zwar darum wie man
aus rosmarin steckling gemacht um den zu
vermehren ich mache das super gerne wenn
ich zum beispiel bei freunden zu besuch
bin und sehe dass die ganz tolle kräuter
haben dann frage ich mal nach ob ich mir
davon stecklinge machen darf und heute
zeige ich euch eine ganz einfache
methode wie ihr diese stecklinge
verwurzeln könnte das ihr dann aus
stecklingen eure eigenen häuser ziehen
könnte übrigens wundern über meine
augenklappe mehr gestern beim melken
meine neue mietspiegel kannst ja die ja
aus dem video hier oben kennt er und in
meinen augen gewandt diese rückwärts
zurückgewichen das war also nicht
böswillig sie ist nur von einer anderen
ziege zurückgewichen und dabei ist es
von meinem auge gelandet es ist aber
nicht dauerhaft beschädigt das muss
jetzt nur wieder heilen und dann
hoffentlich bei das wieder gut aber
schon immer große reden ich zeige euch
jetzt wie ihr und stecklinge ziehen
können das ist super einfach ich packe
euch in die video beschreibung auch
gerne mal eine liste mit ganz vielen
anderen kräutern mit denen das genauso
funktioniert wo es morgen ist jetzt hier
nur unseren beispiel ist ein tolles
beispiel wird sind tolle des krautes
aber es gibt noch viel mehr kräuter mit
denen das noch funktioniert also schaut
auf jeden fall mal in der video
beschreibung vorbei um den rosmarin
durch stecklinge zu vermehren brichst du
einfach ein mindestens 15 zentimeter
langen zweig von der alten pflanze ab
das kann auch ein größerer zweig sein
wir haben das schon sehr erfolgreich mit
solchen lang zweigen und gemacht hier
unten auch schon sehr verholzt waren das
ist also bei rosmarin komplett egal wie
alt der 2 er sollte aber 15 cm lang sein
denn wir werden jetzt die blätter der
unteren fünf zentimeter ab machen so
dass die nicht faulen werden wir den
zwei gleich in ein wasserglas stellen
und da bleibt er dann stehen ich mache
das immer in der küche bis sich feine
weiße wurzeln gebildet haben da muss man
immer nachschauen dass das wasser immer
aufgefüllt ist weil wenn ihr austrocknet
dann sterben die wurzeln ab ich habe vor
ein paar wochen schon mal einen
rosmarinzweig ins wasser gestellt der
ist jetzt fertig der kann jetzt
gepflanzt werden haben sich tolle weise
witzig im gebet
und den pflanzen wir jetzt ins bett da
einfach ein loch ausheben das so tief
ist wie der wurzelballen die pflanze gut
andrücken gut an gießen ich habe den wir
jetzt auch noch hier so ein kleines
stück holz gegeben weil es schon ein
längerer zweiges damit er nicht umkippt
und dann den boden um die pflanze herum
über längere zeit gut feucht halten
damit die wurzeln gut anwachsen können
ich lege nach dem pflanzen immer noch
ein gis rand an um die pflanze also
einen kleinen graben einen flachen
kleinen graben um die pflanze turm herum
so dass wenn man gießt das gießwasser
schön bei der pflanze bleibt und nicht
wegläuft das mache ich mit allen jungen
pflanzen so die ich neue pflanze damit
dass gießen eben schneller geht und das
wasser auch da bleibt wo es hin soll die
frage wo man kräuter hin pflanzen soll
kommt immer wieder rosmarin mag es sehr
sonnig das ist ein mediterranes kraut
das mag es gerne in einen vollsonnigen
beet andere kräuter wachsen aber lieber
im schatten oder im halbschatten sage
soll jetzt also vorher immer nachschauen
bevor du kräuter gepflanzt was sie denn
so für ansprüche haben rosmarin mag es
lieber auf einem trockeneren boden zu
wachsen während zb schnittlauch ist
schon hier ein bisschen feucht damals
der gibt es also ganz unterschiedliche
ansprüche und dementsprechend
positioniere ich dann meine kräuter in
meinem garten sie überlegen immer was
wäre die beste ecke jetzt für dieses
kraut damit es optimal wachsen kann
außerdem bepflanzt ich am allerliebsten
meine beet ränder mit den kräutern
gerade so am weg entlang finde ich das
super schön und viele kräuter haben ja
auch einen starken geruch der schädlinge
für anhalten kann deswegen will pflanzt
ich immer meine gemüsebeete mit den
kräutern damit wir da eben noch so einen
schönen mischkultur effekt haben man
kann aber natürlich auch ein ganz
eigenes kräuterbeet oder eine
kräuterschnecke anlegen das ist auch
eine super idee wenn euch das video
gefallen habe dann gebt ihm gerne einen
daumen nach oben ich freue mich auch
wenn ihr den kanal abonniert ich werde
auch mehr kräuter videos machen haben
wir in plano wir werden bald über
basilikum ein video machen das kann ich
euch gerne da oben verlinkten sobald es
erscheint hier drüben und da unten
findet ihr auch noch spannende videos
die euch interessieren könnten ich freue
mich wenn wir uns da wieder sehen
ansonsten bis nächste woche